hello and welcome to this video playing
the marzipan cat I've played a couple of
games against them or against it if it's
a cat oh right it's been a while iam so
I don't know I've got seven games but it
really feels like it's been a while
since i since up later okay so some be
three ways set up interesting maybe take
sandy five is at the point I just wanted
to play some sky learning on type of
setup yeah five is a good move right mmm
yeah it's a bit of an issue Queen 85
let's bishops III that doesn't work yeah
95 of definitely was a bet okay that's
what I have to play now it's not much
else the dark squares are slightly weak
in white scam and white skin so checks
on a five or before could be could be
interesting it takes its young yeah I
definitely would like to take with the
bishop but g7 is hanging but ok let's
just go for that if he takes it after
trying to find compensation down yeah
little bit
ok the potential compensation is that
the dark squares and said are somewhat
weak between 8-5 problem has to be
answered with c3 which is not
particularly ideal problem is that i'm
also my development it's also not lying
fantastic but ok maybe we should a six
main issue is my king room has
absolutely oh really I didn't have that
on the agenda yes it's possible it's
possible but I didn't didn't really
think of this beforehand someone's go
back c4s Bishop before before there
before is a shady more so not something
I'm particularly afraid of yeah I don't
know maybe this is not objectively
enough but in a blitz game um maybe okay
what's this I cannot take it yet takes
Bishop Jake's bishops III know that
doesn't work I wonder where to go
actually if i go to c7 there's also
Queen gt5 that might be useful but I
like to have a bishop a six in case now
NC 5 is a move that I probably want to
have in store
hmm wait 5 10 5 episode g12 as a bishop
86 so ok let's go a five and now if I
take it and then we should a six maybe
we should basics immediately that is c4
I can't think I have to take it after
see takes the bishop is opened up again
which is not ideal
you know okay after if it takes it I'm
definitely okay I mean that that's
that's very okay very okay my issue is
the rookie and the rook maybe I can go
look too before a g4 and then II form
something like that maybe maybe
something a glad okay so if i do this
now okay f3 maybe I don't have a I can
also take and go see fire or something
simple but I feel I should have
something better here and also have the
[ __ ] g5 Rocha for f3 f3 weakens the dark
squares a lot a lot but I don't see how
to exploit it maybe there is a way to
exploit it I can go g5 no it doesn't
work okay anyway I have to play more
this is not a bad move i think it just
that it fell to me that there should be
something better oh it is a man move I'd
i forgot about sea foam I totally forgot
about that okay maybe this is still
possible actually because of the long
diagonal even though that's of course a
blonde I should have allowed that I
thought first of taking and then c5 but
I didn't say as in cb5 and takes the
form and what a shame what a shame ok
and so let's let's fire him open open
everything up Bishop here is got screen
before ok so
look at you for no F 3 I'm checking the
Hanging Rock so that's not happening
rookie for me me yeah what's going to
have thought about f2m time morning yeah
like this
and can I take it I actually can take it
on Queen takes 93 does win we should be
for worship team one looks very
dangerous which is not as precise as i
would have liked it to be but yeah I
have to be content with that now what is
he doing here okay not sure that I'm
threatening night is three here and
probably threatening just to go back and
then Lin 93 and something something like
that c4 okay I can take and take you
form hmm i don't know what's it for yeah
check take you four years he's got the d
4head if i go here though and I have to
play cooking and I have no time
ah what you played a totally different
move that I expected and the Primo head
check ok this is fine now from position
point of view think quite so quite
irritated by that hitting pretty move
you know and then and then he had played
something entirely different than what I
had anticipated I was extremely
irritating check check check and you
played a different and crap I've spoiled
this stuff and it was a complete wait of
course at one point and snow it's the
dro black for fits on time what a joke
just need two more moves that you get to
pawn oh my god and of course I just
haven't win somewhere there must be this
position is just not going to hold at
least a couple of moves later i'm pretty
sure about that I mean shake so it was a
very very murky game ok but I think it's
correct to give up the porn I mean I
have some compensation that is for the
Blitz game this is pretty a pretty clear
so around here the engine is so in this
quick glance giving an equal assessment
and yeah here probably I should take
instead of allowing this
no the engine actually believes I can
take care to harm this like it doesn't
use don't quite get it yet so what's the
deal queen bee Simon is good I have this
okay interesting ok so I could have
taken ok anyway i'm i'm interested in
the position here i am that then that
gets very very lucky ok the computer
finds the defense with Queen d3 yeah
push fc5 look we should know not ninety
three wins okay try this mmm okay we'll
get three is a pretty big threat so that
was one way to kill it and here so he
there he has no wind okay I'm can I was
thinking I should be it should be
something it looks extremely dangerous
so this wouldn't want you to Queen g2
and here i was totally what did I expect
actually I expected him to take of
course that I thought you would take and
then create three that irritated me
enormously but it's a good move of
course and then here why does I think so
the Queen see six squads are to enroll
yeah I actually think that the road yet
should be ok with we were mostly let's
say that now quick quick moves ok yeah I
I didn't really see that check he's
getting in now here and here here I'm
losing so I only had this one moment in
the complications the
may I actually thought I would be doing
well it wasn't all that gymnastic like
he I was thinking I should be something
which doesn't seem to be doesn't seem to
be I mean I went I went here clam I mean
this is what I saw of course but this is
not clap yeah this is defending
everything in turn of course I'm okay
all right I can take and take but I
wanted to win and this is just a draw I
think but it seems that this is
objectively bad young Queen you one now
this is a murderer's to play so I only
had this opportunity here in 93 hit but
I was happy about seeing Bishop f2 so I
didn't really look any further okay but
this is quite clearly strong mmm 93 is
broken three is extremely strong
something like clap this is also clay
could be a pretty awful attacking with
everything here I can and yeah it was a
very murky murky game basically from
there from the get-go ok guys thanks for
watching